♪
TREY: OCCASIONALLY YOU HEAR OR
READ SOMETHING AND THINK, THAT
CAN’T BE RIGHT.
SURELY I MUST HAVE READ OR HEARD
THAT ARE WRONG.
AND THAT WAS PRECISELY MY
REACTION WHEN I READ SAN
FRANCISCO AND NEW YORK WERE
GOING TO PAY PEOPLE NOT TO SHOOT
ONE ANOTHER OR OTHERWISE COMMIT
VIOLENT CRIMES.
PAYING SOMEONE NOT TO SHOOT US
IS SORT OF WHAT WE HAVE TO DO AT
CARJACKINGS AND ARMED ROBBERIES.
WE PAY MONEY TO STAY ALIVE.
IT’S A VERSION OF BLOOD MONEY OR
EXTORTION.
AND SOMETIMES MONEY IS PAID TO
KEEP SOMEONE ELSE ALIVE LIKE IN
KIDNAPPING CASES, AND THAT’S
CALLED A RANSOM.
SO, YES, SOMETIMES CRIMINALS ARE
PAID NOT TO KILL.
AND SOMETIMES IN THE HEAT OF THE
MOMENT WHEN FORCED TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN MONEY AND OUR LIVES, WE
WILL TAKE OUR LIVES.
I JUST NEVER THOUGHT GOVERNMENT
OR ANY OTHER NONCRIMINAL
ENTERPRISE WOULD ACTUALLY
ENCOURAGE THIS KIND OF SHAKEDOWN
OR EXTORTION.
THINK ABOUT WHERE WE ARE AS A
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
SOME PROGRESSIVES ARE ADVOCATING
FOR CUTTING FUNDING FOR THE COPS
BUT PAYING CRIMINALS SO THEY
WILL STOP AT LEAST UNTIL THE
CHECK CLEARS BEING CRIMINALS.
I WANT YOU TO LET THAT SINK IN
FOR A SECOND.
REALLY THINK ABOUT THAT.
SOME PROGRESSIVES WANT TO STOP
PAYING COPS BUT START PAYING
CRIMINALS.
AND THESE ARE THE SAME FOLKS WHO
TELL US WE NEED MORE SOCIAL
WORKERS AND MORE PSYCHOLOGISTS
BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW HOW GREAT
SOCIAL WORKERS ARE AT PROCESSING
CRIME SCENES AND COLLECTING DNA
SAMPLES.
AND NOW WE NEED MORE CASH CARDS
AND GIFT CERTIFICATES SO THOSE
WHO DO NOT VALUE LIFE CAN AT
LEAST LEARN TO VALUE THE DOLLAR.
MONEY HAS BECOME THE NEW
MORALITY.
WHAT ABOUT NOT SHOOTING PEOPLE
BECAUSE IT’S WRONG?
I MEAN, THAT USED TO BE WHAT WE
TAUGHT.
YOU DON’T COMMIT CRIMES BECAUSE
TO DO SO IS THE BREAK THE SOCIAL
CONTRACT.
IS IT STILL OKAY TO TEACH PEOPLE
KILLING AND ROBBING AND
ASSAULTING PEOPLE IS WRONG, OR
DO WE HAVE TO PAY PROTECTION
MONEY?
WHAT A MESS THIS CULTURE IS IN.
THE TAXPAYERS IN THIS COUNTRY
ALREADY SPEND A LOT OF MONEY TO
PREVENT CRIME.
THE NUMBER ONE CRIME PREVENTION
STRATEGY WE HAVE IS CALLED
SCHOOL.
IT’S CALLED AN EDUCATION.
YOU WANT TO REDUCE CRIME?
MAKE KIDS GET AN EDUCATION.
YOU WANT TO LIVE IN A SAFER
COMMUNITY?
MAKE SURE YOUR CHILDREN AND YOUR
GRANDCHILDREN, YOUR NIECES AND
YOUR NEPHEWS GRADUATE HIGH
SCHOOL AT A MINIMUM.
WE SPEND SO MUCH MONEY ON
EDUCATION SO WE CAN OFFER SOME
HOPE, OFFER A BETTER WAY OF
LIFE, OFFER A GLIMMER OF
OPPORTUNITY.
WE SPEND MONEY ON AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS.
WE SPEND MONEY ON A SOCIAL
SAFETY NET SO THOSE DOWN ON
THEIR LUCK GO -- WON’T GO
WITHOUT HOUSING OR FOOD OR
HEALTH CARE.
WE SPEND MONEY ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION.
THIS COUNTRY ALREADY PROVIDES A
LADDER FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO
ASCEND.
AND A SAFETY NET TO CATCH THOSE
WHO FALL.
BUT APPARENTLY THAT ISN’T
ENOUGH.
NOW WE MUST ALSO PAY YOU NOT TO
KILL US.
WHAT ABOUT THE KIDS WHO WOULD
NEVER IF THINK ABOUT HURTING
SOMEONE ELSE?
WHAT ABOUT THE CHILDREN IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND NEW YORK OR ANY
OTHER LARGE AMERICAN CITY WHO DO
NOT NEED TO BE BRIBED TO FOLLOW
THE LAW?
THEY DO NOT NEED TO BE PAID
RANSOM TO VALUE HUMAN LIFE.
WHAT ABOUT JUST A SHARED SENSE
OF HUMANITY?
WHAT ABOUT THE ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT WE SHOULD ALL FEEL TOWARD
ONE ANOTHER JUST BY VIRTUE OF
BEING FELLOW CITIZENS, FELLOW
HUMAN BEINGS?
WHAT ABOUT THE KIDS IN THESE
CITIES WORKING TWO JOBS; ONE TO
HELP SUPPORT A FAMILY AND ONE TO
SAVE FOR THE DREAM OF GOING TO
COLLEGE?
IF YOU HAVE SO MUCH MONEY YOU
CAN AFFORD TO PAY PEOPLE NOT TO
KILL US, DO YOU ALSO HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY TO PAY PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
GO TO COLLEGE TO BECOME A NURSE
OR A FIREFIGHTER OR A TEACHER
OR, HEAVEN FORBID, A POLICE POLI
OFFICER?
OR ARE WE JUST GOING TO PAY
THOSE WHO ARE THINKING ABOUT
TAKING A LIFE, OR CAN WE AT
LEAST ALSO CONSIDER PAYING THOSE
WHO ARE THINKING ABOUT SAVING
LIVES?
SINCE WHEN DID WE START PAYING
THE TROUBLE MAKERS BUT IGNORING
THE KIDS WHO ARE DOING THE RIGHT
THING?
AND SINCE WHEN DID THE PATH OF
PROSPER IFTY GET PAVED --
PROSPERITY GET PAVED WITH FELONY
CONVICTIONS?
IF YOUR STATE OR CITY IS SO
FLUSH WITH CASH THAT YOU JUST
CANNOT FIND NEW AND INNOVATIVE
WAYS TO WASTE IT, WHY NOT PAY
THE KIDS WHO ACTUALLY DESERVE
IT?
WHY NOT REWARD THE BEHAVIOR WE
WANT TO INCENT RATHER THAN PAY
RANSOM MONEY TO KEEP PEOPLE FROM
HURTING US?
DEFUND THE COPS BUT PAY CAREER
CRIMINALS NOT TO COMMIT MORE
CRIMES.
AND WE WONDER WHY SO MANY PEOPLE